[موسيقى]
تعرفون شنو اهم عضو بجسمنا شنو اللي خلانا
بشر شنو اللي خلانا نتصيد هذا الكوكب هذا
دماغنا دماغنا يمثلنا ينطينا امكانياتنا
واحاسيسنا ومشاعرنا حتى انسانيتنا امور
هوايه بصراحه دائما ما نعطيها حق قدرها
الا ان يصير فرد خلل معين وانا ذاك يكون
الوقت متاخر
دماغنا هو اعقد جهاز على وجه الارض ورغم
كل التطور التقني اليوم لازال دماغ البشري
اسرع من اي سوبر كمبيوتر موجود على وجه
الارض ب 30 مره بس مثل كل ماكينه دقيقه كل
شي يخص عمله منظم بدقه متناهيه بس بنفس
الوقت عطلاته هوايه وعلى الاغلب من الصعب
تصليحها ومع الاسف مدى نقدر نبدلل هذا
الجهاز لليوم فلازم نحافظ عليه
اني بالحقيقه اعنيها بطريقه جيده بس ترى
احنا بالحقيقه شوربه لا تضوجون لان احنا
بالحقيقه اغلب جسمنا اثنين واربعين لتر
بالمعدل وهذا اللي ما يتحرك خلال كل الجسم
ولازم
دائما تنظيمه بعنايه
راح تتفاجئون اذا تعرفون انه هذا دماغنا
سبعين بالمئه مي مثل تقريبا حجم الماي
بالكره الارضيه يمكن مصادفه ما اعرف
بس بنفس الوقت اذا سبعين بالمئه معناها هم
دماغنا شوربه فاعرفك من عندكم اليوم ممكن
احتمال ما راح يتغدون بعد ما يشوفون هاي
الصوره
زين احنا قلنا شوربه واحنا بالعراق
الشوربه اذا ما بيها لحم وبروتين هاي مو
شوربه زين شنو بقيه المكونات اللي وياها
مجموعه من الخلايا واذا نسال الناس نقول
لهم شنو مكونات الدماغ راح يقولون الاعصاب
وهذا بالحقيقه كان اعتقاد سائد الى حبل
عقود قليله بس اكتشفنا اكو هوايه خلايا
اخرى مثل هاي الاولين هاي عباره تلف اعصاب
الدماغ مثل الاسلاك وهاي الخلايا الصغيرون
الصفراء هاي خلايا تعمل على مهاجمه اي
التهاب بالدمار بس الخلايا الاهم مو لين
انا احبها واشتغلت عليها اكثر من 12 سنه
هي هاي الخلايا الحمراء الخلايا النجميه
ودائما نحن نطلع للنجوم
زين اذا حركه المي تتعرض الى كل التداخلات
العصبيه وتنظم حركه الطاقه بالجسم تنظيمها
لازم يكون بشكل دقيق احنا درسنا
بالاعداديه المي يدخل على الخلايا عن طريق
التناضح بس ترى هذا مو حل دقيق اكو هوايه
بروتينات صغيره بحجم الدونات الكعكه
الدائري العفو بشكل الدونات مثل ما تشوفون
هنا اكتشف هذا العالم الامريكي اسمه بيتر
اجري عام 92 وحصل جائزه نوبل على هذا
الاكتشاف الثوري عام 2003 تعرفون لو مثل
ما اوهمتكم انه غلطت حجم الدونات الواحد
هذا الاكوا بورين بحجم الدونات معناها
الخليه الوحده داخل جسمك اكبر منها القاعه
اكبر منها الفندق ترى حتى اكبر من المنطقه
الخضراء فتصوروا حجمها المتناهي
من الامراض من هالشلل ومنها كذلك الامراض
الدماغيه والجلطات كثير منكم شايفين هذا
بس للما يعرفوا هذا مايكل شوميخار بطل
العالم وشركه فيراري للاسف كان تروح في
رحله للتزلج بالجليد اصطدام راسه وحاليا
دخل غيبوبه وباقي عشر سنوات هو بالغيبوبه
وماكو علاج له المؤسف هاي مو بس حاله
مايكل شو اخر هاي حاله 75 مليون شخص حول
العالم وثلاث ملايين وفاه وللاسف اليوم
كدكتورك صيدلاني ما عندنا علاجات لهم غير
علاجات بسيطه وتفقد مفعولها خلال 24 ساعه
لذلك الحل الوحيد انزيل جزء من الدماغ مثل
ما تشوفون حتى نخفف الضغط بس هاي عمليه
مؤلمه ومضاعفاته هوايه وما اتصور اي واحد
من عندنا يحب يروح لها
حسين راح تقولون انه ما دام هذا مكتشف من
30 سنه والرجل اخذ عليه جائزه نوبلاج
هوايه ادويه بالحقيقه لا السبب انه هاي
المي موجوده بكل جسمنا لذلك لازم نكتشف
دواء دقيق يشتغل على الدماغ بالاضافه لانه
هاي البروتينات الوحده من عندها تروح الى
حوالي ثلاثه مليار جزيئ ماء بالثاني
الوحده كل دون تايه تعبر ثلاثه مليار
زينكم ملايين من عندها شلون بالجسم
بس بالدماغ
وهاي الخلايا ساعات موجوده بهاي الخلايا
النجميه الخليه من تحتاجهم تدزهم لي بره
تجيب شويه مي وهذي تستخدم السلالم
الاعتياديه تروح على راحتها زين شنو يصير
اذا صارت اصابه بالدمار خليه تدزهم بسرعه
تدزهم عن طريق المصعد شو نريد نسوي اليوم
معتز وفريق البحثي اريد نشوف هذا
الايميجنسها اذا صار مشكله وهذا بالضبط
عمل بس عمليه اكتشاف الدواء عمليه شاقه
وطويله تطول عشره الى 15 سنه والتكلفه
مالها من هي فكره براس معتز الى ان دوله
تشوفوه بالصيدليه هي ثلاث مليارات دولار
تعرفون ايش قد نسبه الفشل بيها 90% مخاطره
كبرى اقتصاديات دول فشنو العمليه حتى نهكر
هاي العمليه هي اعاده تدوير الدواء ادويه
مكتشفه الامراض اخرى من قبل هيئه الدواء
والغذاء العالميه نقدر نختصر بيها اول
ثلاث مراحل فنختصر مده ونختصر زمن ونختصر
تجارب بشريه
وهذا اللي سويته اكتشفت انه هناك دواء
مصرح لمرض الشيزوفرينيا اسمه
اذا عطيناه للحيوانات المختبريه اللي
عندها اصابات دماغيه او جلطات ممكن مو بس
نخفف المي الموجود بدماغهم مثل ما تشوفون
هنا لا حتى راح يتحركون بشكل افضل وتتحرك
فعالياتهم العضليه والعصبيه من خلال تسلق
السلالم وفعاليات اخرى هذه العلاج تناولت
العديد من الشركات وتم نشره في المجله
الاولى بالعالم بالتخصص اللي هي مجله وهذا
اعلى بحث ذات معامل تاثير بتاريخ الدوله
العراقيه
اشتغلنا اليوم على الاصابات الدماغيه
واشتغلنا على اصابات الحبل الشوكي هل ممكن
هاي الميكانيكيه تطبق على بقيه الامراض
الجواب نعم طورت تعاون مع جروب كندي متخصص
بالجلطات الدماغيه ويستخدمون المعالج
الخطي اللي اكو اربعه منه فقط بالعالم
واكتشفنا انه اذا عالجنا هذه الحيوانات
المختبريه تتحسن كذلك فعاليات الخلويه
والخبر اللي احب اشاركه وياكم انه قبل
شهرين اخذنا الضوء الاخضر لانه نذهب الى
المرحله الثالثه من التجارب البشريه واذا
هذا العلاج راح يكون هو اول علاج لعلاج
امراض الدمار من 70 سنه وان شاء الله
بانجاز عراقي
[تصفيق]
شنو هاي الصوره اللي ورايا هاي وحده من
المجرات زين تقولون ايش جابها هنا اكو 100
مليار مجره اليوم موجوده بهذا الكون وهذا
المجالات هاي المئه مليار هي نفس عدد
الخلايا العصبيه الموجوده
صارت المصادفات هوايه بس الفكره انه احنا
من عندها انه هذه الخلايا لها مفعول كبير
زين انا قلت بالبدايه دماغنا خلانا نتصيد
هذا الكوكب زين ليش احنا زين هسه
تقولون انه هذا الدماغ البشري اليوم بشيله
بايدي اللي وزنك كيلو ونص هو السبب لانه
اثقل من البقيه وهذا بصراحه لا يخلو من
الصحه
بس هاي شلون راح نفسرها زين دماغ الفيل
وزنه خمسه كيلو غرام وثلاث مرات اثقل من
دماغنا زين ليش مو الفيل اذكى من عندنا
الفكره كلش بسيطه انه وجود هذه التشابات
العصبيه السينابسس تتذكرون قلت لكم اكو
100 مليار مجره بالكون ونفسها عدد الخلايا
العصبيه رقم ترى هائل بس هذا واحد بالمئه
من فقط التشابات العصبيه بكل دمار
بهاي الغرفه شقد اكو بالعراق وشلون اذا
استخدمناهم كلهم سوا هاي العمليه تحتاج
طاقه هائله لذلك دمار البشره على صغر حجم
اللي هو كيلو ونص بالمقارنه مع الجسم
يستهلك 20% من طاقه جسمنا وهاي العمليه
تحتاج تنظيم للطاقه ونرجع لهنا للخلايا
النجميه اللي قلت لكم عليها واللي بيها
هاي البروتينات الحلوه اللي سميناها
الكعكه الدائريه او الدونات
كل جهاز يشتغل بدون توقف ويستهلك كل
هالطاقه العاليه راح يكون فضلات هاي
الفضلات تتراكم خلال دماغنا خلال النهار
وتم تنظيفها خلال للعن طريق سيستم جديد تم
اكتشافه مؤخرا سموه
شافوا انه احنا من ننام بالليل هذا السائل
الحبل الشوكي يمر خلال دماغنا يغسله كامل
لذلك دائما احنا ننصح بالنوم الصحي ولذلك
عدم النوم الصحي يرتبط بامراض الشيخوخه
فشنو اللي يصير اذا اختلف هذا النظام شطف
الدماغ وتنظيفه راح تتراكم الاوساخ اللي
هي الفضلات حول هاي التشابات العصبيه تقلل
فعاليتها وبالتالي احنا راح نقول بالاخير
راح نبدي نخسر هذه الاعصاب اللي راح تكون
سبب للوفاه
فعاليه كم واحد بيكم هنا يحب يعيش الى ما
فوق الثمانين وبصحه عاليه والله ارفعوا
ايديكم
بالله اني هم وياكم بصراحه
وين شنو خلي كل اثنين من عندكم قاعدين ويا
بعض يباعون بعيون بعضهم بالله بس باعوا
هيك بعيون بعضكم تعرفون اذا احنا اليوم
بقينا على الوضع الحالي كل واحد من عندكم
من ذول الاثنين راح يكون بيه مرض الزهايمر
اذا ما لقينا علاجات ولا تفرح لا تقول مو
اني وش علي لين اذا انت مو بيك الزهايمر
انت راح تنطي علاج ورعايه صحيه لهذا المرض
المشكله انه دماغنا مو بسمح من الخارج من
الجمجمه من الداخل كذلك بالحاجز الدموي
الدموي فهذا الجهاز يفصل مكونات الجسم عن
الدم حتى اذا صار اصابه معينه بجسمك مو
تصعد الدماغك بس هذا سيف ذو حدين لانه
يوقف 98% من الادويه التي تعبر للدمار
شلون راح ممكن نقدر ندرسه طورنا العالم
تستخدم اللي هي النماذج الحيوانيه بس مع
الاسف هذه النماذج انتاجيتها قليله
وبالاضافه الى ذلك 80% من الادويه اللي
تنجح على الحيوانات المختبريه تفشل بالبشر
تذكروا كل دول كلف ثلاثه مليار ثمانين
بالمئه نخسرهم بهالعمليه ايش راح نسوي راح
نستخدم خلايا بشريه
زين شلون نقدر احنا نشتغل على فرد شيء
احنا ما نلمسه وما ممكن توقف لك واحد
بالشارع تقول له ممكن اشتغل على دماغك ما
راح يقبل ولا اني بس الفكره انه نطور اول
دمار بشري من خلايا بشريه باستخدام تقنيه
ثلاثيه الابعاد وهذا اللي سويته خلال
العمل بجامعه هارفرد
وبالتعاون مع شركه وطورنا اول علاج
للزهايمر من عشرين سنه اللي تم اقراره من
قبل منظمه الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه العام
الماضي فكره بسيطه احنا ردنا نستخدم فريد
شي نقدر نتابع دخول الدواء الى داخل
الدماغ ونتعقبه الى خلال الجزيئه الوحده
لذلك استخدمنا هاي تقنيه المجهر على
الوضوح اللي يتمكننا من ننظر الى هذا
الدواء باستخدام نفس التقنيه اللي
استخدمها علماء الفضاء برؤيه النجوم
هذا الجهاز دقيق كلش والمساحه بيناته كلش
صغيره فقط 170 مايكرونه يعني بالضبط بقد
حجم اظفرك لذلك معتز لازم يطور شريحه
مايكرويه يبني عليها هذا الدماغ البشري
ثلاثي الابعاد حتى يقدر يدخلها هناك ولازم
هم اختار مركب بحيث تنمو الخلايا البشريه
عليه بطريقه صحيحه واستخدمت تقنيه
الثلاثيه الابعاد بالطباعه حتى اقدر ادخل
داخل هذا المجهر نعمل عليه
مثل ما تشوفون مو بس التصميم صحيح وانما
الخلايا كذلك كلمه بالطريقه اللي نتوقعها
داخل جسم الانسان ومثل ما تشوفون يوجد
تجويف داخل هذا الوعاء الدموي الدماغي
اللي يمثل الاول من نوعه بالعالم وتم نشره
قبل سنتين
الفكره انه هنا احنا هذا الوعاء الدموي
الدماغي اذا نريد انه نحقن به الدواء نريد
نتعقب الدواء الى ابعد مرحله مثقله ولذلك
مثل ما تشوفون هنا من حقلنا الدواء تم
احتواءه بالكامل وهذا كان اول وعاء دموي
دماغي بشري ينجح تحقيق هذا الشيء الموديل
اللي طورها معتز والفريق البحثي هو الافضل
بالعالم وهو عشرات المرات مثل بقيه اللي
هم يسموها السيستم ثنائي الابعاد لان
بالحقيقه بسيطه مو لان فقط نتائج معتزل
هنا على اليمنه بالمقارنه مع هذولا
بالحقيقه بسيطه لانه الخلايا بجسمنا عمرها
ما نمت لا على بلاستيك ولا على معادن
الخلايا تنمو بطريقه ثلاثيه الابعاد مع
بقيه الخلايا الاخرى
طبعا الحصول على خلايا الدماغيه امر كلش
صعب لذلك تقنيه الخلايا الجذعيه احدث
الثوره كبيره ناخذ خلايا من الدهن وياريت
ياخذون شويه مالاتهم بصراحه خففون علي
ونحولهم الى خلايا مفيده هوايه من ضمنها
الخلايا العصبيه والخلايا العضليه لذلك
اليوم معتز وفريق البحث بجامعه اوكسفورد
عملنا على تطوير اول خلايا عصبيه مشتقه من
خلايا جذعيه للمرضى الشلل الرعاشي وكذلك
مرض الزهايمر مثل ما تشوفون هنا هاي
الخلايا العصبيه مو بس تشبه الاعصاب لا
تشتغل مثل الاعصاب وتشوفون التشابات
العصبيه والهدف من ذلك هو تطوير اول دماغ
بشري ثلاثي الابعاد يعمل من خلايا جذعيه
مشتقه من هؤلاء المرضى حتى ندرس حركه
الماء وكيفيه تنظيف الدماغ من حائل اوساخ
اليسر عليه ونريد نمنعها قبل ما تصير لانه
احنا اليوم اللي نشخص الزهايمر او اي مرض
من امراض الشيخوخه اتاكدوا هي عشره او 15
سنه من الضرر فان شاء الله خلال سنين
قليله قادمه نوقف على ونشارك الفرحه وياكم
شكرا لاستماعكم لنا
[موسيقى]